what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren and we
have law way every every time we have
law with us uh most of you know law he's
been on the podcast I think every time
we haven't had a podcast without law yet
and he is he's got a video coming out on
the channel later today about Disney's
wish be sure to check it out it's a
review plus you went to the studio it's
gon to be cool and today we're g to talk
about the Marvels because I'm I'm
surprised everybody really wanted me to
talk about the Marvels which I
understand because I feel like right now
the movie has a lot of controversy
surrounding it yesterday on Twitter I
asked people what they thought about it
I didn't do a poll because I genuinely
wanted to hear people's thoughts about
the movie and like I'm GNA say like
90 something percent were positive about
the movie but this is this is where I
just want to tell everybody to calm down
a little bit because I've been on
YouTube and I've been seeing all of
these videos like Marvel is dead the
Marvel sucks this is the end of the MCU
and I'm just kind of like it wasn't that
bad like sure yeah I'm not saying it was
good because I'm sorry I I can't I think
there are a lot of good and sometimes
even great aspects to the film and it's
sad because it had a lot of potential I
feel it had a lot of
potential but I don't think it was like
the worst thing ever that's dooming
Marvel Studios and this is it for them
like right I've seen you know there
there are there are channels that I
genuinely enjoy watching who do spit the
truth a lot um and you know they're
truthful in their reviews but you know
I'm not going to mention any especially
because I like them
but yeah know there's a lot of you can
just find them all online like Marvel is
dead the MCU is dead the MCU you know
what I mean
like but right away I thought there were
some great parts of the movie overall I
just thought it was a mess it dire it
lacked good writing um but we're also
going to break down that post credit
scene too but law right away what what
did you think about it um I definitely
uh all what all of what you said
resonates with me I think I it's
interesting because I had more fun in
this movie than I did Quantum Mania
Quant Mania yeah but did I do I think
it's a better movie than Quantum Mania
that is a question I I've have yet to
answer I think I need to watch it maybe
one more time to just like really
develop better feelings about it but I I
totally resonate with the fact that yes
there were some great parts that really
work but not within the context of the
film that we have um which was a little
bit frustrating because it's like you
know it almost felt like there were just
bits of story missing bits of character
develop development missing so much and
and not to cut you off but to add to
what you're saying real quick before I
forget uh the the difference for me for
Quantum Mania and this movie is the
villain okay makes it a better movie
sure because like I like no offense to
zwe like actually in this review no
offense to any of the actors because I
actually think they did the best with
what they were given I don't think this
is their fault at all I think it's liter
it's literally the direction of the film
it's the writing right uh I don't think
it's them I actually think Brie Larson
was more relatable this time as Captain
Marvel yeah way way more enjoyable on
screen yeah this time around yeah she
really was and uh you a Paris and Iman
bani stole the show she stole the show
and that's what literally even in these
even in these uh YouTube videos that are
just crapping on the movie everybody's
like yeah Miss marel sauce well well
that's the thing you can't you can't
crap on her because it's she had the
most character she was the most
character you know what I mean everyone
else was auxiliary almost and and and I
think if they had really focused on her
path and like what she was going going
through because there's just like
there's just moments where I was just
like what why is there no consequence
why are we not talking about what they
all just saw you know um why do I care
about the relationship of uh of Monica
and Carol you know I mean that's the
problem is you don't it that was what
was missing you know you know like uh I
think it could have used I know it's
like a breezy you know 90 minutes and it
does feel really nice and it's easy to
watch yeah but but 20 more minutes of
character development would have done
some good for the film overall
especially the villain and especially
for
Carol see I don't know if you agree with
this but this is kind of not not
necessarily spoiler territory but this
felt like a sequel to A Captain Marvel
movie that we didn't get see see yes yes
yes because I'm like I want to see her
get married I want to see her like
destroying Supreme intelligent like all
of that stuff you know what I mean like
like this should have been the third
movie there should have been in between
this could have been the Ragnarok you
know like a little bit light
lighthearted teamup film um
change yeah yeah so those are my initial
thoughts of the film uh I think it's
funny because like you mention like MCU
or Marvel is dead it's like look we're
we're not innocent yeah we're not
innocent with those headlines either for
like for like videos in general no of
course not generally work they get click
yeah it but generally in our discussions
we don't say it's dead you know like we
we there's Nuance to it right right that
said I think that's an overreaction I
think the movie was enjoyable uh which
is what a movie should be uh but do I
wish it was stronger in story and
character absolutely and that's kind of
how I feel about it overall yeah and you
know oh man here here's the deal here
here are my thoughts on the movie
they're kind of like
because I don't think it was it's
definitely like in the bottom 10 of MCU
movies like I'm you know just gonna be
honest there it is but it's really
really really not as bad as all these
Doom headlines are making out to be and
I understand what everybody's doing
they're getting clicks and a lot of
people are riding this wave especially
the people who hate the so-called MCU
right I mean I I understand what's
happening here and it was a mess and
here's the deal I didn't care about the
villain at all mhm because they didn't
give me a reason to they didn't they
didn't take any time for character
development and it felt everything kind
of felt cheap like the knock she was
what are they calling her the dollar
store brand of ronin the accuser and I
feel so bad that she's getting that
title I feel so bad that she's getting
that title because it's not her fault at
all it's it's really not her fault at
all and it's like oh oh yeah that's the
Universal Weapon like Carol damis just
mentions I hated that line I hated that
line line just like these throwaway
lines where it's like oh that's what
this does like the exposition had no
Nuance to it it just was thrown in there
yeah and then you get glimpses like very
very small glimp glimpses of what this
movie could have been sometimes when you
get like really good chemistry between
the three leads rightt and you're like
wellow and then it's like the part with
uh uh Miss Marvel Cala where she's like
we have to save these people but Captain
Marvel's like we can't we got to go we
have to save the ones you the ones we
can I love or I would have loved if they
Dove further into the fact that Kamala
is actually meeting this Idol that she
looks up to getting a glimpse of true
superhero life like having to save a
whole entire like planet and race and
everything like that and she realizes
like holy crap this isn't actually what
I thought it was like yeah people die
and Captain Marvel isn't this just this
happy go-lucky girl who just saves
everybody like saves everybody all the
time like she's actual person with flaws
and it's like there was so there you
could have went into that and it would
have hit so hard I I think that was
exactly the move that should have been
done is yeah is Miss Marvel is now
seeing that Carol or Captain Marvel is
is not devoid of of you know um I mean
people get hurt no matter what yeah and
it should have been like oh my hero
couldn't save everyone is she is she
really a hero you know like that is
interesting especially for a young a new
young hero on the uh on scene that would
have been a really big impactful moment
but 20 seconds later two minutes later
they're like jump roping a spaceship
yeah you know what I mean like yeah and
like um H yeah so those those are my
major complaints but yeah I have to keep
coming back to the fact that like I was
still having a good time I was laughing
out loud and like you said I really
liked what Carol was in this um I even
laughed at the weird silly Nick Fury
even though he should be depressed as
hell after a secret Invasion uh but he
was he was a joy to watch uh albeit a
little confusing uh maybe he's a scroll
I don't it's it's so conflicting because
I'm like first of all you don't mention
secret Invasion at all yeah and I was
gonna that's what I was gonna say you
literally have Fury and the cre how do
you not mention it whatever I digress I
I laughed at Fury's character but I was
so pissed the entire time because I was
like this isn't the fury we just saw the
fury we just saw isn't the fury that
we've known over the course of you know
the infinity Saga so they're
just I I think Marvel entered a state
where they were like we want to treat
each project like it's its own thing and
I'm like that's good to an extent but
you have to keep continuity with
characters totally you can't just be
like we're gonna make him the goofiest
character blah blah blah and in my mind
I'm like why is kamala's family there
why is her family there you would never
take her family into space like you
would just you would never do that right
like why why to protect them from what
nobody knows who they are and you just
got the two cre that were there right
yeah the the the the switching of the
powers was cool I just I wish we would
have got like the final fight was
so quick
it was and I wish we got a lot more of
that because it was actually pretty cool
what we saw I was gonna say some of
actually the fight choreography in this
movie is some of the better fight
choreography in the MCU with the power
switching with kind of utilizing like
kamala's kind of slippy nature and and
you know uh Monica's Powers seeing them
in in like battle was really really cool
because the last time we saw her was
just W division she's just like you know
phasing through things throwing punches
there's a moment where she like phases
through a guy and then punches him after
coming out that was that was sick I
remember being like Oh you know my hopes
were so high for the rest of the movie
after that point um I also love when
they kind of dampen Carol's Powers a
little bit so that she's more ground
level with everyone else even though
she's super op um which makes the whole
Sun thing kind of contradictory well
this is
sorry I just before I forget yeah don't
want to be rude but I will forget
because I I saw this today I saw
something and uh it was by like a
Captain Marvel account and I never
bashed on people who like love Captain
Marvel I like her um I just think she
needs more Justice in writing with the
movies yeah and I like Brie LaRon but
they were like talking
about Thor and how he's like oh you have
Thor the God of Thunder who struggled
to like hold the energy of the sun when
creating a Stormbreaker right in
Infinity war and then Carol just goes
through the sun I'm like this is
actually like they meant that as like a
really cool thing I'm like but this is
actually the problem yeah because here's
the deal good stories don't just make
these characters come out of nowhere
sure who are invincible we look like
there's no relatability to that like for
struggle is amazing MH and that's and we
love to see the heroes overcome their
struggles and Rise Above and get
stronger through them and then they're
stronger at the end right they're not
just Invincible the entire time so
that's like a big writing problem that I
think they actually had to deal with in
this film they're like we made Captain
Marvel way too strong how do we Nerf her
and and it was it pissed me off because
she's sitting there fighting Dar Ben and
sometimes losing and I'm like in no
freaking way is she less strong you know
what I mean it's like even with that
weapon Nega thing yeah right it's like
and then what pissed me off is like okay
so darbin puts both of the bands on and
dies and then Mr Marvel's like cool no
big deal I can handle all this you know
I'm like what is this inconsistency why
did darbin die because she couldn't
handle the power but they weren't even
concerned about Cala I I almost feel
like it's like a ride off you know like
they hope that you watch Miss Marvel so
that it's like oh because she's mutant
and her family's connected to the new
realm you know what I mean but I will
agree with you it it feels very um cheap
I guess for a lack of a better better
term it feels
cheap and it happens so fast that you're
like wait shouldn't she be also glowing
and exploding or something you know
um I think what you said is
unfortunately how I feel about a lot of
what happened happens in this movie
cheap uh cop quick cop outs just it it
was messy I think everybody even in the
really positive comments I got on my
Twitter everyone's like it was a lot of
fun Messy as hell no plot and it's like
yeah it's like you liter at the end of
the movie you you literally showed us
what could have been done from the very
beginning and it's like you know what I
mean and and and it's like it makes no
sense so you took out the Supreme
intelligence and their son went away
this incredibly High Advanced
civilization yeah one how are they
controlling the sun with their AI why is
that why is that a thing that's not how
yeah like the resources
depleting I like the idea behind it uh
and like the mission behind the villain
but I agree that I was it was it was so
underwhelming especially because in the
first movie and Captain Marvel she's
like you tell them I'm coming you know
she's like she makes this big threat and
then we get this quick flashback scene
of Carol standing there blowing
everything up and then suddenly the
Earth that they live on goes to
like why I wish right yeah I just I just
needed more of that you know what I mean
now I'm gonna I'm gonna transition us a
little bit because we have to talk about
it because there's the silly moments
yeah well I want to talk about the silly
the silly scenes people are like oh I
hated the musical Planet I hated the
flurin scene those were two of the big
highlights for me as weird as they were
it's one of those things that are like
this doesn't belong in this movie though
this belongs in like love and thunder
you know what I mean yeah so I hated the
singing scene hated it did you poor par
June man they did I love him so
much and I think that's what made me
hate it even more I was just like this
is how you doing parks of June and it s
probably his only movie in the
MCU but I I think that was a problem is
you know the director was like this is
going to be silly I'm like one of my
issues I think I've had with the MCU
recently is that it's actually been too
silly I you if you look at if you look
at the infinity Saga there's some silly
stuff in there you get like Ant-Man and
stuff but like there's a lot of meaning
in Ant-Man too like with his daughter
with hope and everything and with Hank
like there you you care because it's
serious and I didn't care about what was
happening in this movie because it was
so silly and then the it was so I don't
even care that it was silly Just the Way
It Was Written when they're like they
want you to care about the relationship
between Monica and Carol and I don't
because you didn't give me a reason to
totally you know what I cared about I
cared about how Miss Marvel saw Captain
Marvel because that was set up in Miss
Marvel right and I went with my mom
because I was sick I didn't get to go to
the screening so I went with my mom the
day it came out and she left and she was
like why were they
switching and she was like okay but why
did why was the the girl switching
because of light Bas Powers right and
she was like yeah and she was like and
the girl in the white suit Monica uh
what was her powers again I was like
kind of whatever they felt like having
at the time like you know what I mean
like yeah her powers aren't that very
well defined well I so I interviewed Nia
dasta on the carpet for uh d23 and uh we
were talking about Powers I I mentioned
that to both her and tiona and I was
like
you know uh spectrum's Power set
whatever name you want to give her
because they didn't give her a name in
this
movie yeah but I was I was saying she's
like her power set is so nebulous right
it's so it's so Grand it's it's
basically manipulation of light and
matter and and she was just like oh we
had to choose like a couple things so
that uh it didn't seem like she was too
powerful but the fact that like some a
Layman you know goes into the movie and
doesn't know what those couple things
are that's a that's a big issue and um
bad writing and it's rough Sor and it
sucks because like I wanted Captain
Marvel to return to the
theaters with a big win because I I
really hate how Brie Larsson has been
treated uh on the Internet by the fandom
like I I I personally feel for the
person behind all that um and I I don't
know I just um I wanted to like this
more than I did I don't hate it I think
uh I think that's something that we can
continue to agree with is just like it's
not bad bad but it's not great and I
wanted it to be great I want it to be
great I did like it more than the first
Captain Marvel even though from a story
perspective I think Captain Marvel is
stronger if if that makes sense I I
don't know something about this made it
more enjoyable maybe it was the
light-hearted tone maybe because like we
hadn't seen Captain Marvel with that
levity
like the flk scene when she's like here
kitty I thought that was so adorable I
loved her scenes with Fury uh Carol and
fury I thought their chemistry was
really wonderful yeah wish it all made
yeah I just wish it made sense in
context of like what's going on in the
universe right now yeah and it doesn't
that's sad and then just the lack
of a villain really in all honesty like
the lack of a villain and and if you
think about it the final scene wasn't
even really about the villain it was
about like the Multiverse AR part which
like no like Monica wasn't set up super
great yeah it was like like the way they
described it and she could also could
have like totally done it from our side
of the universe like based on how but
whatever um overall we'll finish this
we'll talk about the post credit scene
so overall like yeah it's definitely in
like the lowest of the low for me uh for
for movies um but I don't know if by if
it's better than the first Captain I
will say this these videos that I have
watched you know dogging on it they do
speak the truth when it comes to the
first Captain Marvel film everybody
thinks Captain Marvel is like really
really loved character I think Marvel
might have thought this too because of
because it did a billion dollars but
like holy crap that was the peak of the
MCU and you stuck it between Infinity
war and Avengers endgame and basically
told us you had to watch this film yeah
right it's it's like everybody saw it
because they had to and it was like holy
crap Infinity war is amazing this we
have to see this now it's like it's like
you have to take that in consideration
totally and I think
Marvel very very very much overestimated
how much people like that but you know I
was hopeful for the movie because I
thought it had a lot of potential and
you can see some of that potential in
the movie but overall it's just poorly
written it's poorly written it's
underdeveloped story-wise which is I
guess just another way to say it's poor
um yeah just from the villain to the
giving us some time to actually know and
care about some of these characters in
the relationship each other just you
know it was rushed it was quick and I
hated the singing But the post credit
scene
um they really pushed that post credit
scene with some promos they had yeah
they did one where they like left the X
and they were basically telling us the
X-Men are here they're coming and I'm
like oh like before the film even came
out I'm like I know it's in the post
credit scene and you're sitting there
promoting like the X-Men are showing up
I was like oh Marvel knows this movie is
not good I was like you know what I mean
and you know there's some people out
there who genuinely love movie I'm
really happy with those people yeah I
and I bet you if I watched this movie on
its own it wasn't connected to Marvel in
any way right it was its own thing I
would have liked it a lot more but I
know it's connected to the
MCU uh and I know the characters before
you know captain Marvel their story
development everything is just it's
unfortunate but going to that post
credit scene a comic accurate Beast I
don't I'm going to ignore the CGI it was
very rushed because it was look like an
insomniac game yeah does it does it does
rushed yeah it was rushed because they
had to put something in there to attract
people to see the movie like let call
let's call it what it is let's call it
what it is and you know we're going into
Deadpool where those Fox X-Men are
coming and yeah it's cool to see and
that's actually really cool because I'm
assuming we're going to
get half and half I'm assuming we're
going to get
um like their original outfits from the
original movies they were in but then
upgraded outfits maybe more com accurate
outfits right totally because we've seen
Wolverine right we've already seen he's
got the comic accurate you know
Wolverine skin so in the post credits
you know uh she's in she arrives in
Another Universe She closes the the the
whatever you want to call
it she ends up stuck and we'll call it
the fox X-Men Universe because as far as
we know that's that Universe it could be
another universe that we haven't seen
you know in the I I I would argue it
might even be X-Men 97 the animated yeah
because because it looks like you know
Charles and Multiverse of Madness had
the yellow chair the yellow yeah you
know and then this Beast very much looks
like the Hank McCoy a lot of us grew up
with on on in the cartoon so I'm I'm
hoping it's kind of that yeah like but
you're right it could just be like oh no
this is the fox Universe we just like
revamp the designs a little bit because
we didn't want to put Kelsey Grammar in
Prosthetics you know I mean right
exactly well and Okay ignor C yeah this
we're gon talk about what it means what
it means is basically it's a prep for
Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars yeah right we
all know now and they've even said in uh
Sean ly even said look out you know like
like we're not ignoring the fox X-Men
Universe right there's a lot that came
before and we already know cameos are
coming in right most of the original
X-Men I think are coming back like uh uh
you know cyclop cycl Phoenix or I guess
Jean FKA Hollyberry you know Jam yeah uh
they're they're coming back which is
awesome and so and what do we hear him
say like Professor X or Xavier wants an
update
or yeah like that right so we know he's
there um so we know actually that's a
point it's not the a38 universe because
he's dead3
Universe yeah so I would love actually
for it to be the 97 Universe since
they're coming out with that show maybe
they link those live action in secret
Wars so totally basically what they're
doing is they're showing us that hey now
we are crossing over into you know the
other
universes like kind of like not
intentionally crossing over which
because that's the whole problem that's
the whole Secret Wars deals the
incursions like unintentional Crossings
of the universe CU keep in mind in 838
those weren't universes Crossing into
each other we had a character from our
universe take a portal basically to
another Universe this was literal
incursion like two universes were
colliding a portable the you could see
into the other one right that's not how
strange was right Strange's body got
taken to another one this is like actual
universes that's what it's prepping us
for it's prepping us for
incursions and
uh the the the the interesting thing
about it is is you know again I'll go
back to my mom who was with me and she's
like who's that you know what I mean you
know and I had to explain the entire
thing and it's kind of just like oh like
from with with h Jackman's Wolverine I'm
like yeah so like that's a whole that
didn't happen in in the MCU from Iron
Man you know that didn't exist in this
same universe I was like explain
Multiverse to her like I'm a freaking
physicist here you
know let me explain theoretical physic
real quick mom and so I take a and you
bend a paper and you poke on just
Interstellar so but then she she was
like oh that's pretty cool I'm like it
is really cool don't you wish it was
explained better yeah exactly that's
whole point is like you know what I mean
but I I think for us fans we knew
exactly what was happening it was really
cool to see yeah but that that's that's
a big problem I have with just like the
Multiverse in general right now like Dar
Ben yes that is the villain of the
Marvels by the way if you forgot her
name because I definitely did halfway
through the movie guy in the comics
there there you go so but Dar Ben I
thought the whole vibe was gonna be she
was this multiversal villain who was
stealing artifacts through different
universes ripping holes in SpaceTime
because that is how it was marketed
presented that way it was presented that
way and then when I
found no you're fine yeah yeah no no no
when you found out when you found out it
wasn't when you found out it wasn't when
you when you found out it wasn't then I
was like when is the Multiverse stuff
going to happen because because it was
such a big part of the marketing and
then it all it's all in the third act
where it's just like oh there's a hole
in SpaceTime this is an incursion I need
it's not even the third act it's like in
the last 15 minutes maybe it's in the
last 90% of like it's 10% of the movie
yeah and then when you leave off on that
post credit scene it doesn't feel
finished the movie doesn't feel finished
at that point doesn't even really feel
like it was part of the movie no yeah
yeah totally it's just like this extra
thing yeah going going back to the
marketing then they started marketing
that like darbin was like finishing
thanos's work and yeah what was that
about not related to that at all like at
did not love the way they marketed the
film unfortunately yeah and not it's
it's sad because it's basically the
studio going like oh my gosh this mov is
not fa which sucks because I think I
think if they leaned into what it was
people would have watched it for what it
was it's it's like a fun jaunt through
space and time with three characters
that you know you know what I mean like
and I do love the teamup aspect I did
like I did like some of the chemistry
the power switching was interesting it
was why why pull endgame clips and
Thanos clips and talk Multiverse if it's
not really that's not what the bll or
the the meat of the movie was the meat
of the movie should have been their
interpersonal relationships like not
only the power switches
yeah damn P from
YouTube that's crazy but it should have
been about the power switch and all that
you know I always feel like like I
picture in my head it's like you have
all the events of the MCU going on and
then it's almost like a com comic book
and then you go to a page that says
meanwhile yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean it could have been a separate story
on its own totally totally it was and
also another thing is like I feel like
not everything in the MCU has to be like
Universal threat No No in fact I love
the first Ant-Man because it's not you
know what I mean it's so contained in
its in its own thing and like I love
that about about MCU movies when when
they can do that this phase you haven't
been able to do that this was a actually
a great opportunity to do so but then
they were like trying to pull in from
all the things that you remember and and
I don't know
as yeah I wonder how casual fans feel
about you know the story because it's
just all this setup of like something's
coming hey thanks for watching this
movie Something's coming soon yeah you
know yeah the good news is I think
Marvel is fixing things right now yeah
that that's that's definitely seems to
be what is happening right now yeah i'
I've heard that they're actually
Consulting now with Christopher Marcus
and Stephen mcely who yeah so really
great writers really great writers who
have done a lot of great work for the
MCU um so and there's been a lot of
articles that basically from like Ry and
Hollywood
Reporter deadline they're basically like
yeah Marvel knows and they're trying to
fix it right now and the fact that they
made all these delays is them going you
know what we're not putting these movies
out because they're not good we need
more time and the only mov still coming
out next year's Deadpool 3 because Ryan
Reynolds has taken like six years to
rate this thing so you know it's going
totally yeah so the good news is Marvel
I think is working on it and I did a
video not yesterday day before maybe
yesterday maybe day before depending on
when you watch this could be a week now
week ago but um that was like I was
talking about I was like if Marvel fixes
one problem it pretty much fix
everything else and that's the writing
like Loki season 2 was great because
they finished the writing before they
filmed yeah same thing Galaxy volume 3
they finished the entire thing before
they filmed uh She-Hulk they were
writing it kind of as they went along
because they realized something sucked
and needed changing and they had already
filmed so they had to redo some stuff
and add more CGI and which made the CGI
bad because they didn't have enough time
to finish it like writing is the problem
we need good stories we need to care
about characters and their stories which
I I didn't care about like in this movie
at all which was the problem but overall
it it's not the end of the MCU it's it's
it's really not as bad as everybody
really it feels like a side Adventure
it's like a side quest during all this
like all this multiversal stuff um it's
definitely not the worst thing I've ever
watched um and you know I think that's
reflected in kind of like not that I use
Rotten Tomatoes as like sure as like a
great you know what I mean like it's not
a great way of judging a movie but
critics hated this movie audiences are
seeming to really enjoy it like General
audiences I'm cool with that you know
like that's what a movie should do you
should go in Escape for a little bit and
enjoy yourself if you if if it if you
achieve that with this movie great but
you know like you and I we have to we we
critique things every now and then we're
fans but we're also reporting on this
stuff and like you know like it we we
need to you know it's our job to almost
pick out flaws and certain things but at
the end of the day not the worst thing
in the world I think all the reactions
that were saying that just need to like
you know uh reel it in a little bit but
at the same time we've had a little bit
more time to kind of like create the
Nuance of what we thought of the movie
because it's you know it's a a little
you know a week ago now is that was that
when it came out uh and we've seen the
the ticket sales kind of perk up since
the word of mouth so it's like like you
know it's not it's not going to be a
billion dollar movie not like the first
Captain Marvel but no I actually heard
that it's it's GNA take like a 70%
drop
yeah but uh but yeah let us know what
you thought about it um yeah I mean I
think it's what you said law it was for
those people who just want to go see a
movie and have a good time and you don't
take it too seriously it's probably
pretty good and at the end of the day
it's still Marvel action it's still MCU
characters and
yeah I I do I do will I will keep saying
this the the fight scenes are great I
think they're really good them yeah
should have got more of them there's
just a lot of continuity errors with
this movie and bad writing unfortunately
could have been great but it is what it
is go ahead and let us know uh what you
think about it down below in the
comments and also look out for Law's
video on wish wish new movie coming out
it's supposed to be a classic you know
one a new a new modern classic spoiler
alert for the video I really enjoyed it
yeah look out for that that'll come out
today as well and uh yeah let us know
what you thought about the Marvels give
us your honest thoughts pure honest
thoughts whether good or bad we'll catch
you guys in next video woof woof